[Musique]
ce n'est pas son odeur qui attire la
rada n'est pas une plante aux parfums
délicats elle n'a pas non plus une
apparence impressionnante août d'environ
un mètre et iberia aléas ca présente des
feuilles oblongue d'un vert foncé et une
erreur très prononcé ces fleurs tout
petit moins de 10 cm sont blanches avec
un petit coeur vert
mais cette plante qui paraît anodine est
pourtant très prisé
originaire d'amérique tropicale où les
indiens d'amazonie utilisent depuis des
générations
elle a également trouvé sa place dans
les régions tropicales la caraïbe bien
sûr mais aussi l'inde et l'afrique son
nom change au gré de ses voyages on
l'appelle anna mot dans les pays
hispanophones comme la colombie le
panama ou la république dominicaine
à la dominique la rada s'appelle kuruk
[Musique]
dans de nombreux pays elle fait partie
des rituels magiques mais aussi des vies
mais drg asie
il faut dire que le champ de six
applications est impressionnant
tantôt consommer pour lutter contre les
douleurs musculaires
dentaires les rhumatismes
maux de tête grippe asthme sinusite ou
troubles digestifs
au bénin comme dans certains pays
d'amérique tropicale
les feuilles macérer sont posé sur le
ventre des femmes en simple pour
déclencher les contractions lors
d'accouchements difficile
car la rada possède des propriétés
abortives
dans sa composition on retiendra aussi
la présence d'antioxydants
d'halloween qui apaise notamment dans
les infections de la peau
mais aussi de pi little un glucide
particulier qui aide à lutter contre le
diabète
et cette plante cache encore bien des
secrets comme nous le révèle l'équipe
scientifique du parc par exemple
l'essentiel des feuilles et des racines
d'arada à montrer justement des
propriétés antibactériennes donc
clairement on peut conforter en fait
certains usages justement en cas
d'infraction de la peau par exemple un
autre point qui est intéressant c'est le
caractère impulsif et iggy ton vis-à-vis
de aidé sa légitime que justement
envisager à terme le développement d'une
solution anti moustiques pour l'avoir
1,5
[Musique]
de nombreuses pistes s'offrent donc
encore aux chercheurs pour valoriser la
rada mais quelle que soit la raison pour
laquelle vous voulez l'utiliser
n'oubliez pas d'être prudent si les
plantes peuvent soigner mieux vaut
demander conseil à votre médecin
[Musique]